- Good morning Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is Believe,
and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
we're going to today how
to follow your dreams.
Over to you, Aaron Marino.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning,
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
♫ I wake up every morning.
- I met a woman that I
helped lose 100 pounds.
And she came to me and said,
"Hey, I want to start a fitness center!"
And this, for me, was my dream.
And it was tough, I
didn't make much money,
it didn't matter because I was happy,
I was doing something I loved.
We took some loans,
and got some investors.
There was a big issue with
one our investors and my business partner,
and it ultimately ended up
in lots of legal fights and battles.
We had to end up shutting
down this business.
I was dead broke, I was bankrupt.
In order to make ends meet,
I was driving a beer
cart at a country club.
And I'm sitting there with
tears rushing down my face,
because I don't know where to go.
I was at the lowest point
that I ever have been.
Giving up was never an option.
The problem was
that I didn't know what
success looked like anymore.
But what I do have
is a dream and a desire to help people.
At the time, there really wasn't anything,
any resources out there for regular guys
to get some solid, basic advice on how
to look good and feel great.
I decided that I was going to help men
feel better and amazing about themselves.
So, I have a video camera.
I was the least tech-savvy
person you'd ever meet.
But I picked it up and I
decided that I was going to try
and film a video and put it on YouTube.
Everything changed for me.
I found that new vision,
I found that new passion.
All of a sudden, I had a
voice, I had an audience.
And I was doing something
that made me feel incredible
because I realized I was doing something
to help other people.
- Most people quit on
their dreams too soon.
They just quit too soon.
You don't realize that to have success,
you have to try and try and try and try,
keep improving and keep
trying to find another way,
until you eventually hit it,
and that's the story of
any successful person.
They tried so many different ways
until they had the thing that
helped them break through.
And too many quit way too quickly.
And you need to explore,
and say yes, and try things
until you find that thing
that makes you come alive.
And so for Aaron, it was YouTube.
He tried all this other
stuff, and nothing was working
and he knew he had
something bigger in them,
and he didn't want to
play the safe life, right?
He didn't want to take
that failure and then say,
"Okay. That's just not going to work."
"I'm going to go and
work at a retail store."
Right, he didn't give up
on doing something bigger,
even if he didn't quite even
know what that bigger thing was
he didn't give up.
Most people quit right there.
You need to continue to explore.
He stumbled into YouTube,
and that became the thing
that he then exploded with.
For me, it was going to the YMCA.
And delivering a speech that
was I was super proud of
to go and help entrepreneurs
when they invited me in,
and only three people showed up.
You know, three people
showed up to a free event.
How was I ever going to
turn this into a business,
and make money from it?
But because I went,
and because I loved it,
and because I enjoyed it, I had
to find a way to keep going.
Even if I never made money from it,
I had to find a way to keep
doing it because I loved it,
because it became my dream,
because the feeling that
I got when I was doing it
was intoxicating.
I couldn't wait to go and do it again.
I just found this thing
that helping entrepreneurs
was something I found so satisfying.
And so I had to find the way to continue.
And that's the thing with dreams.
A lot of times they don't
make sense at the beginning.
You don't quite know how
it's going to work out.
You don't necessarily have
that final end goal yet,
because it's brand new,
because you haven't done anything yet.
And so you've got to figure it out.
You won't get to that success
by sitting on the couch
and thinking and thinking
and seeing other people
make a lot of money
and other people going off
and chasing their dreams.
You have to get up off the
couch and do something.
People often ask me, "When do you quit?"
And I'm not the guy that
says never, never quit.
Really the answer comes down to,
is it still your dream or not?
Are you still passionate
about this thing or not?
If it's still your dream,
and you just haven't figured out a way
to make it happen yet,
then you have to keep going,
you have to keep doing it.
Like Aaron and his transition to YouTube,
you have to find different
options and keep testing,
until you find the thing
that's right for you.
The alternative is,
you're going to live the
rest of your life in regret.
You're going to think, "I wish
I just gave a little bit more."
"I wish I tried a little bit harder."
"I wish I pushed more on
this thing to make it work."
And you settled for an average life.
But if you don't have the passion anymore,
if it just feels like work to you,
that's when you quit.
If it's not your dream anymore,
then you quit and you move on to
the next thing that is your dream.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious: what is your dream?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
Write it with some passion,
with emotion, with feelings
so that when you read it back you're like,
"Yeah! That's what I'm
doing. I'm pumped about it!"
Let me see what you got.
Leave it in the comments.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Eric Seuret from 3smobile,
Eric, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, I really, really,
really appreciate it man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever Your One Word is.
Much love,
and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot
of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning.
♫ Entspresso keep me going.
- I, I truly believe, and
people throw the word around,
dreams, it's all about dreams.
And by the way, dreams cost nothing.
They're free.
Uh, the hard part is
just keeping them going,
and please, keep them going.
Because we're here for one simple reason.
He believed in the dream,
I believed in the dream,
and our dreams come true,
and there's no reason every
one of yours can't either.
Thank you very much.
- It sounds so cheesy,
but follow your dreams.
Like for me, I have 100
percent belief in that if
somebody really wants
something and really has the,
and really is eager to work hard for it,
you can make it happen
or you can at least be
very very close, you know.
So, yeah.
It sounds cheesy but follow your dreams,
and spend as much time as
you can trying to improve,
get better, learn new things,
and it's never too late
to learn new things.
For me still, every day
I get to learn new things
and that's the fun thing.
You never know everything.
Every single morning, Monday
through Fridays at 9:00 AM,
I host a live call-in radio
show on Sirius satellite radio.
It's called Make it
Happen with Mel Robbins.
And the thing that's been
so crazy about that show is,
every single person that
calls me on that show,
they call in because they're
feeling stuck in their lives,
and they're resigned about their ability
to change their lives.
And I'm not talking about
people that are nuts.
I'm talking about successful
people like you and me,
that just somehow got
stuck in their lives.
And I'm not talking about people
that are looking for cheesy self-help,
I'm talking about people that really want
to figure out how to
move themselves forward.
And I find that so many of
us think that our dreams
are unreachable, or unrealistic,
and it's just so sad.
I mean, people think that
their dreams disappear.
And if that's what you
think, congratulations,
you're officially stuck.
And the truth is that our
dreams are always there,
and they don't ever give up on us,
we give up on them.
But here's the secret. If
you just force yourself,
and I mean force, because I know damn well
none of you want to do
anything about this.
And I also know you're sitting there like,
"Yeah, this self help
crap, this isn't for me."
But if you just force yourself
to take a couple small steps
there's always a surprise.